five years ago there were about 150
scripted shows on American television
now there's over 300 that's an explosion
and there are new production companies
on the internet pop all these Nuka hell
overstock.com has decided to start a
television production company right so
what you see in the next year or two is
an additional hundred feature written
features coming into television I tell
my students even if you're a snob and
you only love movies all the tools we
teach you work in television - the only
difference is in movies your heroes heal
in television they just keep bleeding
but every other tool we give you works
great on television so try TV because
look at all the fantastic stories
television is telling right now and it's
the markets only getting bigger so I
think that television is because there's
no more rules about what you have to say
because there's no more strictures help
I got a note I was working with a great
writer a few months ago on a TV show and
he sent in the pilot we'd worked on it
together and we got a note back from the
producer and here's what the note said
I've never seen this ever before the
note said can you make it longer I never
received that note ever he wanted the
pilot to be two and a half hours long
and he also said he'd make it darker -
now this would have never been said five
years ago because television story was
very strict and you gonna tell her you
know it's a 45 minute for an hour you
know maybe and cable you can go to an
hour but all those rules are gone so
television is taken what the movies used
to have exclusively and added the fact
that now we can tell endless stories
that go on for hours and hours and hours
and it's great it'll work people will
support it so this is why television
works so well
for our age and I don't think there's
any I don't think that's gonna stop I
can it's going to continue so we teach a
lot more television now than we do
movies
you